so live PD has been pulled by A&E the
show was a hit revealing an unspeakable
truth that cops are human maybe that's
why it was canceled for showing the
police as hard-working folks facing
unpredictable and sometimes dangerous
circumstances and because that didn't
fit the current narrative it got pulled
and this reveals that the real
censorship doesn't arrive via autocracy
but the emasculation of network execs
here's an idea
replace live PD with no PD just so
crimes committed without cops around oh
yeah that was the riots but the networks
made sure not to show much of that so
we'll live PD come back
now when the meet media sees police as
somehow worse than criminals and live
Peavey's crime is showing the reality of
policing ignored by other networks where
cops are either relentlessly heroic or
horrifyingly bad and so A&E cancels it
censorship out of fear do you know that
up to four hundred and forty thousand
Americans die each year from preventive
Hospital errors that's the third leading
cause of death in the u.s. so shall we
cancel Grey's Anatomy and all those
other Hospital programs that show health
care workers in an aspirational glow and
believe me I say all of this knowing
full well that live PD was my
competition they put up great numbers
every Saturday night so I should be
thrilled they got knocked out of the
lineup
I could be number one but that's stupid
and wrong because I may not be number
one I may be next so uh Jesse you were a
big fan of this show I was always iffy
because I always I didn't like live
programming showing people at their
worst circumstances you know when you're
really drunk and do something stupid
like this show yeah belt it the big
lesson from live PD was how substances
played a role in like 90% of the of
these these conflicts
somebody's wasted and in that unravels
two lesson yeah it shows you the human
condition
especially that when you got to see that
methamphetamine and heroin have really
ravaged large parts of this country as
you said you were right it really
humanizes the police and it gave you a
crash course in criminal law like if you
get pulled over with a small amount of
cannabis you don't have to resist a
runaway it's just a ticket relax and if
you're cooperative and polite respectful
the police usually give you a pass live
PD was the truth it was live unscripted
unedited programming isn't that what we
want don't we want millions of Americans
to be watching what the cops are doing
on the weekends don't we want
transparency body cameras full
accountability this is what this was it
did a million in the demo almost as good
as you Greg but a million in the demo
which is astounding and it shows you how
many people watch the show
black Americans white Americans Hispanic
Americans because you know every hour
one of the bystanders of the subjects
would look at the camera and say live PD
what up so it was probably internal
pressure that caved because there was no
boycott attempts there was no mass
insurrection on social media I think
they panicked at A&E and maybe that they
did make cops look good or they were
guilty or they were just scared but this
hurts social justice this doesn't help
social justice you know wide in the
monologue I called it censorship which I
realize strict if definition it's not
because this is you know private
companies they can cancel the show
whenever they want but it is a four
isn't it a form of censorship when
there's when people decide to close
something down because they're scared of
I don't know the media I mean it's it's
an external pressure that causes you to
run away it's a it's a different it's a
new kind of censorship so I was I have a
different take Greg I was thinking maybe
it's internal pressure maybe it's an act
of conscience maybe they you know are
attuned to the fact that so much in the
culture right now is so
uncomfortable with the relationship that
the police have with so many in the
black community but in the community in
general in terms of use of excessive
force and so they just think you know
it's just not right now I buy the way I
had predicted to Jesse that Annie would
not cancel this show because the show is
popular I think it's their number one
show on any it is I think so it to me so
they took a real step they made a real
sacrifice by doing this but I would just
I mean from my perspective I think it
oftentimes results in very negative
portrayals not only of black people but
Latinos even poor white people I mean
obviously they're not going into big law
firms and finding a you know some drug
dealer in the bathroom this is street
crime so it's a heavy load of people on
the streets and to my mind you know I
could say this directly to all of you
would you want a TV camera in your face
on the worst day of your life and would
you want that to be seen by all of
America the worst day of your life I
just think that's what the show
basically boiled down to is kind of you
know you know a peaky a peek look at
people in their most distressed awful
condition yeah I mean I always felt that
I agree with that part but I don't think
that's the reason why it's being
cancelled Emily I want to play you a
clip from President Trump we just heard
this moments ago about what would happen
if we didn't have police I'm thinking
what happens late at night when you make
that call to 911 a there what do you
have what do you do whether you're white
black or
else what are you doing you're dialing
and there's somebody breaking into a
house and it happens to be a violent
person Emily you have a choice you can
discuss that topic or the topic we were
doing on lyd PD it's up to you
thank you I'll just quickly say I think
we meet we need more footage not less I
would love for the public to understand
what happens in the 24 hours after
voluntary surrender at jails on Mother's
Day in women's jails on Christmas at
prisons just everything what's printed
on the outside of meat boxes going into
the cafeterias the public needs to see
more of the entire criminal justice
system not less hmm you know Dana this
is this is a program owned by Dan Abrams
also owned something called Mediaite I'm
sure that won't get canceled but he's a
deputy he's a liberal he's a thoughtful
liberal Democrat and he's being eaten
alive by his own so it what's
interesting is I think that in some of
the proposed legislation federal money
would not go to police departments that
do not have everybody in body cams right
so this footage is important in in some
ways right so they're gonna they're
gonna want that I had a hard time ever
watching any of these shows because I
hated the feelings that I got from it I
would get so nervous for everybody I
remember getting pulled over one time
for a speeding ticket and I was I was
mortified I wanted like self punish
myself I feel bad for Abrams because I
think he had a good product and they
made a decision that a lot of will
disappoint a lot of people yeah I and
you were right to be nervous dating when
you were pulled over speeding because
you did have you left out the fact that
you had two bodies in the trunk so I was
back in the days when you were just
roaming the countryside
picking off drifters